this was their official welcome the red
carpet rolled out as they landed in
jamaica
all smiles but already it's clear more
difficult conversations lie
ahead before they'd even landed
protesters were gathering outside of the
british high commission demanding that
prince william apologize for the role
played by the royal family in slavery mr
william i see you love to dance with the
black people
and
you love to frolic but
speak some truth on this trip
speak truth for what it's worth clear
time the duke and duchess william they
haven't done anything to us but they
represent
they represent
a certain kind of history that is
unpleasant for our people this visit how
much is the queen paying for it isn't
jamaicans the one that are
pain-free
along with demands for reparations come
calls that jamaica becomes a republic it
was motivated by the recognition that
it's time we've grown up in 60 years
it's also fostered by the reality of the
kobe pandemic
so it's about a new narrative and a new
direction that must be led by the
jamaican people
and we need opportunities to have our
voices heard that must be part of a new
institutional arrangements founded in a
new constitution
discussions that are coming right from
the top
prime minister andrew holner said
jamaica has to cut those ties with the
royal family in the future
barbados becoming a republic last year
really ramped up the debate
prince charles used that moment to
acknowledge the pain of the past
from the darkest days
of our past
and the appalling atrocity of slavery
which forever stains our history
the people of this island
forged their path with extraordinary
fortitude
the couple don't see it as their role to
dictate what jamaicans should do they're
here to listen and we just wait to see
if that is really welcomed